Hi, I'm Erik Voss and it's here guys!
The Game of Thrones season 7 trailer, our
first look at the new season. HBO is
calling this trailer the Great War and
it has everything we love about battles,
cavalry charges, cities being sacked,
pirates, big maps! Now there is so much in
this trailer and I'm going to break it
all down frame by frame everything you
might have missed with some theories and
predictions for what we'll see over
these seven episodes so let's get
started. "Enemies to the East...enemies to the west...
enemies to the south... enemies to the north."
Okay, so the opening shots shows Cersei
in the red keep, and right away there's
something interesting here: Cersei looks
like she's wearing fur. King's Landing
remember is normally pretty warm so the
fact that it's already sweater weather
this far south suggests that she also
must be feeling that winter is here
along with the threat that winter brings.
Now this first section of the trailer
features Cersei listing her enemies
closing in on her from all directions of
the map. East with grey worm and the
unsullied invading from Essos, west
Theon and Yara's Greyjoy's ship from the
iron islands, south what looks like one
of the sand snakes from Dorne sharpening
a knife or a spear, and North the little
ninja north of the neck, Arya. By the way
it's interesting that the editing makes
it so that the northern threat isn't, you
know, 'Da King of da Norf' or even
scarier - the White Walkers, but I guess
that while those may be bigger threats
neither of them hate Cersei as much as
Arya does, so in a way that kind of makes
her deadlier. Now each of these threats
and directions play over shots of the
stone map table at Dragonstone. Now very
similar to the opening title sequence of
every Game of Thrones episode, the camera
soars over this starting at King's
Landing, following the Kings Road north
past Duskendale along the Blackwater
Bay, then through the Veil of Arryn, then
to the wall, and this is interesting
because this battle map is actually
being shown not from the point of view
of the Queen who's currently plotting
her defenses, but from the Queen trying
to unseat her, Daenerys. This table was
built by Daenerys's ancestor, Aegon the
Conqueror, who conquered Westeros
on the back of his three dragons, and
that exact history is something that
Daenerys is planning to repeat and
another thing: check out how the angle of
this shot on the table frames the
fireplace in the background with the top
where the wall is on the map. Now a few
shots in the trailer later hint at a huge
battle sequence that's set in the north,
probably later on in the season and in
this shot making the wall look like it's
on fire
could be foreshadowing that battle. And
before I move on, the music of Game of
Thrones is always awesome, composer
Ramin Djawadi is really at the top of
their game, and in this opening section
he uses mostly strings, violins but also
upright double bass, and if you listen
carefully with the perfect pitch that we
all have, that super low bass note there
is a C, which is the lowest possible
pitch of any stringed instrument. Like,
normally the low note on a bass is tuned
to an E, but if you release that string
and make it looser, it can extend lower -
to a C. "This up here is called an
extension, which allows the bass to go down to a low C.
So, why does Jarate do this?
Well, for one - this is a super low
note and it definitely produces a sense
of dread, which is totally what Cersei is
feeling as her enemies close in on her,
but also extending this low E to an even
lower rock bottom C suggests that as bad as
things are for Cersei right now, it's
still possible for things to descend to
an even worse place for her and all the
characters when this great war really
begins. Alright, let's move on.
"Whatever stands in our way, we will defeat it.
We're the last Lannisters. The last ones who count.
Okay, so in this section we see that like
Daenerys, Queen Cersei has a big map of
her own. She's converted the red keep
courtyard into the big floor map, like that
Carmen Sandiego game show. Now notice
where Cersei is standing here. She's
standing on the twins. That's the location
of the Lannisters largest victory, the
murder of Robb Stark at the red wedding,
which ended the war of the five kings, but
that area is also called the neck of
Westeros, as if Cersei is stomping on the
neck of the Seven Kingdoms, choking them
with her terrible rule. Meanwhile, check
out Jaime here. That sword he's carrying is
widows wail, that's Joffrey's old
Valyrian steel sword which Jaime's father
Tywin created by melting down the Stark
broadsword, ice, into two smaller swords.
Now Jaime carrying the sword is
significant for a few reasons. According
to George RR Martin, when Joffrey died
widow's wail was sent back to Casterly
Rock. Location actually shows up later in
this trailer.  So maybe this means that Jaime
was at Casterly Rock for this battle,
retrieved the sword and now he's come
back to report to Cersei what happened.  Also, remember the other Valyrian steel
sword that was forged from ice was the
one Tywin eventually gave to Jaime,
which he then gave to Brienne called
Oathkeeper. So considering Jaime and
Brienne are of course the star-crossed
lovers that we all want to see end up together,
hopefully these twin Valyrian steel
swords will lead the way to this reunion.
Another cool way that this could go is
Jaime might use widows wail to make
another certain widow wail, Cersei. One of
the big theories that we brought up in
the past is the Queen Slayer theory that
Jaime's destiny is to repeat his fateful
decision to strike down the Mad King, but
this time a Mad Queen. So not only would
this affirm the Voland Cara prophecy
from the books, where the wood witch
warned Cersei that she would die at the
hands of her younger brother, this would
be some nice poetic justice here, with
Cersei dying from the same Valyrian
steel of the Stark family that she
screwed over so royally. Next, as the
Lannister army marches in the battle,
which looks awesome, by the way, we've never
seen their armor look so vivid, we get
this shot of Cersei on the Iron Throne,
and notice how she's replaced the
seven-pointed star with her Lannister lion.
Remember she did away with the state religion by
nuking the Scept of baler at the end of
last season, so it makes sense that she would
remove any religious iconography and make
things all about her now. Also who is
talking to Cersei in this shot? It looks
like some man with short hair, and
judging from Cersei's disgusted look here,
I'm thinking it could be Yuron
Greyjoy. And the reason I think that is
that Yuron's storyline in the show
seems to be following the character of
his brother, Victarion Greyjoy, who's only
in the books, and part of that character's
journey is to pledge to make an
alliance through marriage, and that could
be what Yuron is doing here with
Cersei, maybe offering to... "get my big
c*ck." Now whether or not it goes that
way, I'm guessing no, Yuron would
still be the only potential ally that
Cersei has left, and his fleet could be
the only thing that protects her from
the massive Navy that Daenerys is
bringing her way. Now when Cersei implies
that Tyrion is a Lannister who doesn't
count, we cut to Tyrion with the three
dragons on Dragonstone, and I'm guessing
that Cersei underestimating Tyrion is
definitely going to blow up in her face
somehow. Also notice how the sounds of
the troops marching from the Lannister troops
earlier continues through this shot as we
move on to Tyrion on Dragonstone. The
sound editing suggests that all these
characters are in their own way marching
to war. Alright let's move on.
"I was born to rule the Seven Kingdoms...
and I will."
Okay so here we see Daenerys's
long-awaited homecoming to her
birthplace of Dragonstone. The gates open
up, and she sees her Targaryen family
sigil, the dragon, on the window of the
castle above. I also like how this shot
focuses on her touching the shore, kind
of like a warrior coming home from war
and kissing the ground. This moment is
Dany's first contact with Westerosi
soil since she was a newborn. Also,
notice how the music in this section
changes. There's heavier percussion, and
if you listen closely, it sounds like a
voice is whispering the three syllables
of Khaleesi.
"Kha - lee- si"  "Oooh... do it again." "Kha - lee- si"
It's almost as if as Dany returns to
her ancestral home, on her way to the Iron
Throne, she's remembering her past
leadership roles, one of them being
Khaleesi, that led her to this point. Next
up is one of the most interesting parts
of this trailer: the unsullied sacking a
city with Lannister banners, and yea,h
that's probably either Casterly Rock
or the larger port city that it
overlooks, Lannisport. That banner kind of
looks like it's in an L shape. So, this is
a big deal. This is the ancestral home of
the Lannister family, and we've never
seen it on the show before. Like, Casterly
Rock has always been talked about, but
it's always been considered untouchable.
Remember, Robb Stark planned to attack it
right after the red wedding, but
obviously he never got that chance. But
now that Cersei has made enemies out of
everyone in Westeros,
her Lannister army is probably spread
thin across the countryside defending
her rule, which could have left her home
city undefended. And, now it looked like
Daenerys can deliver on Robb Stark's old
plan, deploying the unsullied to strike
right at the Lannisters heart by taking
their home. Also, this would have even
wider implications. Remember, the source
of the Lannister's power is their
reputation as the wealthiest family in
Westeros, "the Lannisters always pay their
debts," but in the past, Tywin revealed that
the family is secretly broke. The gold
mines of Casterly Rock have all run dry
years ago, and now that an outside force
is sacking the city, that secret could
become public knowledge,
causing Lannister stock to plummet, doing
further damage to Cersei's power and
reputation. All right, let's move on.
"The King of the North!
You father and brothers are gone, yet here you stand.
The last best hope against the coming storm.
If we don't put aside our enmities, and
band together, we will die." Okay, so this
next section takes us to the north, as in -
"The King of the North!"
and joining John in Winterfell, if you look
closely, is Brienne, who apparently made
it back safely from Riverrun. And in this
wide shot of the hall of Winterfell, you
can see Littlefinger on the side, along
with Tormund, the wildling, sitting among
the northern houses. Also, there's one
northerner who looks a lot like the pro
wrestler, Eric Rowan,
like, Cleganebowl still sounds fun and now
we got someone who can tag in, but then
we get this moment between Littlefinger
and Sansa, and, just like he did at the
end of last season, Littlefinger is still
trying to empower Sansa over Jon. Like,
nothing against Sansa, but I would still say
Jon is the last best hope against the
coming storm.
Clearly, Littlefinger is just trying to
worm his way into influence by
upsetting the power structure in Winterfell.
And, later in the section there's a
mysterious shot of Littlefinger's dimly
lit face, either in the Winterfell crypts,
or maybe in a dungeon. So it's possible
that Littlefinger's meddling could land
him in trouble in Winterfell. And then,
after this icy shot of the northern
gates of Castle Black opening up, we cut
to fire, jump cut of ice and fire, if you
will, to Theon surrounded by flames,
maybe as a ship burns around him, I have
more thoughts on this late. But we also
see Melisandre at Dragonstone. Now it
makes sense that she would return to
this place after Sir Davos banished
her from Winterfell at the end of last season.
This is where she first came into the
picture, making sacrifices on the beach to
the red god, and birthing Brother-killing
smoked babies, but look mostly at who she's
gazing down at, walking along the narrow
pathway. That looks like Tyrion down
there, along with a figure wearing a big
cloak, and I'm guessing that's Jon.
There's been a ton of leaked set photos
that have hinted that Jon will appear at
Dragonstone, so this could be confirming
that, but also based on this plea for
unity that we hear from Sir Davos, it
sounds like they're both on a diplomatic
mission to Daenerys, trying to get her to
join forces with them to take on the
White Walkers.
Remember, Dragonstone is also rumored to
contain large quantities of dragonglass,
one of the few known weaknesses of the
White Walkers, so that could be part of
their mission as well. But my prediction
is that this whole meeting will be set
up by Melisandre, who left things in a
pretty bad place with Sir Davos and Jon,
and is probably looking for a way to
redeem herself. There are also
two quick shots here of wildlings, or
maybe northerners or Rangers dressed up
in wildling furs, running and then
circling up defensively in a blizzard.
If you look closely one of these guys is
holding a War hammer, so yeah they're
probably facing off against White
Walkers, suggesting that these shots are
either part of an excursion that people
are making north of the wall, or this is
part of a big battle scene that's
supposed to take place at the wall,
rumored to come later in the season. Okay,
let's move on.
"And then it doesn't matter
whose skeleton sits on the Iron Throne."
Okay, this section shows us more battle
shots, with the cavalry charge by the
Dothraki bloodriders, now notice how they
synchronize when they rise and perch on
their horses preparing to leap off at
the same time. I'm really excited to see
how well choreographed this whole pitch
battle is. Now where is this battlefield,
exactly? My prediction is that Daenerys
is going to divide her forces that we
saw with her at the end of season six.
Like, we saw her send the unsullied to
attack Casterly Rock which is on the
west coast of Westeros, and then I think
that these Dothraki are invading
Westeros from the East in the crown
lands near King's Landing. Meanwhile, I
think there's a third branch to Daenerys's
forces: her Navy commanded by Yara and
Theon, joined by the ships that we saw
from the Martel's from Dorne and the
Tyrells from Highgarden, and I predict
this Navy is what will face off with the
massive fleet of Euron Greyjoy,
which is what we're seeing in this fiery
ship battle. If you look closely, Raiders
from one ship are boarding the one
that's on fire, and one of these guys is
carrying a shield with Yuron's sigil, and I
think this is the same fiery place that
we saw Theon in that earlier shot. It's
looking like this battle with his uncle
isn't going too well for him. And then
check out this line from sir Davos:
"And then it doesn't matter whose skeleton sits on the iron throne."
Now based on the lighting on his
face and the words that he's picking,
this seems like something he's saying to
Daenerys in the dragon stone throne
room. Now, the image of a skeleton on the
Iron Throne... well, it's super spooky for
one, but it also connects to Daenerys's
vision back in season two, when the red
keep was destroyed and covered in snow:
An apocalyptic future where no one wins
the game of Thrones. So hopefully Davos's
scare tactics here will remind
Daenerys of this memory and the overall
big picture. We also get this quick shot
of the Mountain, now wearing new black
Kingsguard armor. Now, ever since
Cersei resurrected him and stole the
throne in one swift move to become an
evil Emperor, I feel like her
relationship with the Mountain is very
parallel with the Emperor and Darth
Vader in Star Wars. And yeah, this new
shiny black helmet and armor definitely
completes that picture. Now there are two
quick shots in the Winterfell crypts
where Jon seems to shove Littlefinger
against a wall. It actually kind of
reminds me of the way Ned shoved
Littlefinger against the wall in season one.
Now this is interesting, because one of
the big questions after season six was:
now that we know
that Jon Snow's parents are actually
Lyanna Stark and Rhaegar Targaryen, how
will Jon find this out? And what will
happen when he does? And one possible
answer that I've brought up before is
Littlefinger. Remember, back in season
five there was a scene with Littlefinger
and Sansa in this same spot in the
Winterfell crypts at the grave of Lyanna
Stark. And when Sansa said that Rhaegar
kidnapped and raped Lyanna,
Littlefinger went silent and gave this
interesting expression, as if he knew
more to the story. So it's possible that
Littlefinger is one of the few people
in Westeros who knows the truth about
Jon's parentage. Now sure, he wasn't there
at the Tower of Joy but Littlefinger was
there at the tourney of Harrenhal, which
is where Rhaegar first made a move on
Lyanna, handing her a blue rose instead of
his wife, Elia Martell. Ooh, scandal! And
maybe through his network of informants,
Littlefinger learned that Lyanna and
Rheagar's love was actually consensual, and
when Ned Stark returned to Winterfell
with a baby, Littlefinger was able to put
two and two together. I always knew the
Honorable Lord Stark
never father a bastard. So maybe
Jon's outburst here is a reaction to
Littlefinger telling him the truth, like
either he thinks that Littlefinger's
lying,
There's no Targaryen blood in my veins,
or he's mad at Littlefinger for not
telling him sooner, or he feels
threatened that Littlefinger might use
this information against him somehow.
Like, if Jon isn't the son of Ned Stark,
rather his sister Lyanna, that might kind
of weaken his claim to the Lord of
Winterfell, and possibly Da King of da Norf.
Like, technically Sansa has a stronger claim,
or Bran, once people find out he's still
alive, or maybe none of this legitimacy
stuff matters. Like, the guy did come back
from the dead and win the battle of the
bastards. It's a pretty strong claim. And
before I move on to this final section,
there's a quick shot of a crippled hand
reaching out through a door. Now at first,
this opening looks like the one leading
to the dungeon room that Cersei left
Septa Unella in at the end of last
season, but then look at these wounds on
the arm. That looks a lot like greyscale,
so I'm guessing that this is actually
Sir Jorah Mormont,
with his greyscale getting way worse, and
maybe now he's forced into this quarantine
dungeon okay let's move on to this last part.
"The Great War is here."
Wow, okay lots of big stuff here, so let's break
it all down. First, we're back at this Dothraki
charge, with a blood Rider swinging his
Arak, and that is a Lannister soldier
there. So this huge pitch battle that
we've been seeing shots of will be a
showdown between the forces of Daenerys
and Cersei, and I'm so pumped for this
epic clash of Queens. Also pretty pumped
for this clash between these two- Yara
and ilaria, but they're not the only ones
who are getting any action, there's also
this shot of Grey Worm and Missandei
getting some too. And then there's this
look of Jon and Tormund running for
dear life, with Jon in wildling fur,
suggesting that he was one of those guys
in those earlier shots and this is all
part of the same big sequence. We also
see Daenerys using a piece from her map
table to knock over the Lannister lion
like a chess piece. And this shot reminds
me of the way that Catelyn and Robb moved
pieces around on their war board as they
planned their assault on Casterly Rock.
Again, I think this callback is
intentional and Daenerys intends to
deliver on that same goal. And then after
we see these two figures fall in the
water escaping what looks like dragon
fire, we hear the roar of a dragon and
the most epic shot of this trailer:
Drogon, grown to the size of a freaking 747,
soaring over the Dothraki charge, and I
might just be seeing things, but look
closely at Drogon's head here: there's a
little bump behind it, and that could be
a spike, or part of its tail, but I think
that's Daenerys back there. There was
actually promo material from the show
that showed Daenerys on Drogon's
back. If so, it would be amazing to see
Daenerys lead the charge in the battle,
which would actually be a callback to
the way Jon Snow opened the charge into
the epic battle from last season,
The Battle of the Bastards. Really, I cannot wait
for the season to come back in July, but
in the meantime here are some lingering
questions about this trailer, and what we
know about season 7. 1)Is Daenerys
doing the right thing by attacking the
Lannisters, as much as we're dying to
see her do so, instead of turning her
sights north on the White Walkers? Like,
I'm curious to see if that ambition to
reclaim the Iron Throne at all costs
will come back to haunt her in any way.
and 2) Was there any character that you
wanted to see more of in this trailer?
Like I know, I know, it's
obviously Sam and Gilly, like hopefully four of
the seven episodes of the season will just
be them talking about their baby. Really,
I'm curious to see what
Arya's next move is. Like, obviously she's
headed to Winterfell, or home, but will
she complete her revenge list? And will
she reunite with Nimeria? We'll see.
Okay, that is everything I noticed in
this trailer. We're going to start
talking about Game of Thrones a lot more
on this channel, so keep an eye out for
more Game of Thrones theories and
breakdowns, maybe some new Game of
Thrones related shows with some special
guests... And let me know what you think in
the comments and if you like this
video, please hit like and subscribe to
new rockstars. You can also contribute
to us on patreon. Thanks so much to all
of our current patrons, you guys are great,
especially Wilhelmina Ebbesen. You
can hit me up on twitter (@eavoss) with
any thoughts you have about Game of
Thrones, or follow new rockstars on
Twitter (@newrockstars) for updates on
our videos. All right, thanks for watching, bye.